en este vídeo vamos a poner algunas
estrategias para la división cuando el
cociente no es un número entero es decir
cuando tenemos un número decimal
entonces vamos primero a tratar de
calcular 3 entre 2 pausa el vídeo y ver
si puedes encontrar que es igual y ojo
te voy a dar una pista este no es un
número entero muy bien ahora vamos a
trabajar estos juntos y como todas las
cosas en matemáticas hay varias
estrategias que pueden usar para
encontrar la solución de 3 entre 2 una
estrategia es bien vamos a volver a
escribir esto pero ahora como una
fracción entonces 3 entre 2 lo puedo
escribir como 3 este 3 que tengo aquí 3
sobre
este 2 que tengo aquí oh bueno podrían
decir que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que tres medios pero como podemos
expresar esto como un decimal bueno
pueden reconocer que tres medios es lo
mismo que dos medios más un medio me
permite escribir esto esto es lo mismo
que me voy a hacerlo con mucha claridad
que dos más uno dos más uno es tres esto
sobre dos aquí estoy haciendo cada paso
espero que esto te sirva para que las
cosas sean muy claras y bueno esto es lo
mismo que dos entre dos más uno entre
dos es decir podemos descomponer dos más
uno estos sobre dos en dos sobre dos más
uno sobre dos ahora dos sobre dos es 1
entonces esto va a ser igual a un entero
con un medio
y bueno inmediatamente me pueden decir
oye pero puedes escribir un médium como
cinco décimos y esto está exactamente
bien si no quieres enunciar cada paso
podemos decir que esto es igual a un
entero y cuando escribimos en forma
decimal podemos expresar cantidades en
décimos o centésimos o milésimos
entonces un medio es lo mismo que cinco
décimos y si queremos expresar esto como
un decimal bueno pues ya es muy fácil 1
y 5 sobre 10 es lo mismo que 1.5 un
entero y 5 decimos ahora bien aquí dice
cada paso cuando tengan más práctica
dirán muy bien esto es lo mismo que tres
medios y bueno dos entran una vez en
tres y queda uno entonces será un entero
con un medio es visto como un número
mixto y podrás decir que un medio es lo
mismo que 0.50 en su forma decimal así
que me quedarían 1.5
y bueno otra manera en la que podremos
haber planteado el mismo problema es la
siguiente observa que no estoy
obteniendo un número entero cuando
dividido tres entre dos así que podemos
pensar que tal vez tengamos algo en
términos de decimos así que permítanme
expresar cada uno de sus términos en
decimos entonces tres es bueno 3 es 30
décimos y esto lo vamos a dividir entre
2 ok entonces 30 décimos divididos entre
2 esto es lo mismo que en 15 decimos
déjame escribirlo 30 entre 2 es 15
decimos lo que es igual a 10 décimos y
cinco décimos o 1.5 y regresamos de
nuevo la respuesta correcta es que ambas
son estrategias igualmente legítimas
éstas nos sirven para encontrar cuánto
estrés entre 2 a mí en lo personal me
agrada un poco más la primera ya que
aprovechan lo que sabemos sobre
fracciones pero hagamos otro ejemplo
hagamos unos ejemplos más porque esto es
bastante divertido muy bien vamos a
encontrar ahora amd
es 34 entre 4 y como antes pausa en este
vídeo y traten de encontrar cuantos esto
traten de ver si pueden usar algunas de
las estrategias que hemos visto en el
vídeo anterior muy bien entonces como ya
dijimos podemos volver a expresar esto
como una fracción esto es lo mismo que
34 sobre 4 ó 34 cuartos ahora a que va a
ser igual esto bien 4 caben 34 8 veces
cabe 8 veces y van a asombrar 2 entonces
me quedo con 8 enteros y dos cuartos
8 enteros y 2 cuartos este número mixto
déjenme repetirlo dije que 4 cabe en 34
8 veces y me quedo con 2 entonces me
quedo con dos cuartos otra manera si
quieren ver todos los pasos es volver a
escribir esto como 32 sobre 4 + 2 sobre
4 32 sobre 4 esto es nuestro 8 ok
entonces 8 enteros y dos cuartos bien
ahora dos cuartos es lo mismo que un
medio y si queremos expresar lo en
términos de decimos esto me va a quedar
como 8 y bueno un medio ya vimos que es
exactamente lo mismo que 5 decimos
entonces 8 y 5 decimos que si queremos
expresar lo como un decimal
por supuesto me quedarían 8.5
8 y 5 decimos y hemos terminado ahora
vamos a hacer otro de estos en realidad
hagamos uno donde estemos dividiendo un
decimal donde el mismo decimal está
siendo dividido ahora pensemos en que
vamos a dividir 8.4 entre 7 pausa el
vídeo y ver si puedes encontrar la
respuesta entonces cuando ven esto
inmediatamente
seguramente dicen bueno hacer que 84 es
divisible entre 7 sabemos si conoces la
tabla del 7 sabemos que el 7 por 12 es
84 o de otra manera
84 sobre 7 es lo mismo que 12 pero este
no es 184 es 8.4 entonces cómo podemos
resolverlo bien una manera en la que
podemos plantear lo es en términos de
decimos ya que en 8.4 es lo mismo que 84
decimos y si dividimos 84
en 37 bueno 84 veces cualquier cosa
dividida entre 7 va a ser 12 veces esa
cosa entonces me quedarían que esto es
igual a 12 décimos y 12 décimos lo
podemos volver a escribir como 1 y 2
decimos
1.2 y hemos terminado entonces esto es
1.2
bueno pues otra manera en la que
podríamos haber planteado esto es poder
haber dicho bueno observar tenemos 84
decimos entonces esto es lo mismo que 84
sobre 10
de hecho median esto como un 84 decimos
yo le quieren dividir esto entre 7 y
bueno esto va a ser lo mismo que y ahora
ojo dividir entre álbum es exactamente
lo mismo que multiplicar por el
recíproco entonces esto es 84 sobre 10
por 1 sobre 7 que es igual bueno podemos
cambiar es más déjame escribir de esta
manera esto es lo mismo que 84 sobre 10
por 7 y ahora podemos simplificar esto
si dividimos el mirador y el denominador
entre 7 me quedaría 84 entre 7 eso es 12
y 7 entre 7 es 1 y bueno tengo 12
entre 10 y 12 sobre 10 lo cual es doce
decimos que es lo mismo que 1.2 podremos
escribir esto como 1 y 2 decimos o 1.2
bien vamos a hacer un último ejemplo que
está bastante relacionado con esta idea
digamos que ahora queremos encontrar
cuánto es 7 dividido entre 70 bien pausa
este vídeo y trata de encontrarlo ahora
volver a escribir esto como lo hemos
estado haciendo como 7 sobre 70 como una
fracción y en lugar de escribir 70 ahora
voy a escribir 7 por 10 y lo que es útil
es que ahora podemos simplificar tanto
el numerador como el denominador si
dividimos ambos entre 7 observa si
dividimos el numerador entre 7 tenemos 1
y ahora si dividimos el denominador
entre 7 tenemos aquí un 1
recuerda mantenemos la misma fracción si
hacemos la misma operación en el
numerador y en el denominador
y entonces nos vamos a quedar con uno
sobre eso que se expresamos como un
decimal es un décimo 0.1 undécimo bien
otra manera de plantearlo es bueno esto
es lo mismo que siete entre siete por
diez déjame ponerlo siete entre siete
por diez porque siete por diez y 70 y
ahora otra manera de plantear
exactamente lo mismo es poner siete ya
esté dividido entre siete ya esto
dividirlo entre diez y bueno de aquí
claramente se puede ver que siete entre
71 y nos quedamos con uno entre diez un
décimo o 0.1